last week everyone and their mum was
excited to see another week of ls
coaching cloud nine and pulling out some
of the weirdest most creative drafts the
lcs has seen in years but then minutes
before their game cloud9 released him
and the reaction from the community has
been a collective
what the actual [ __ ] this week the
mystery has only gotten deeper and now
we've already reached a point where
lawyers are involved
yeah let's go through it all
[Music]
hey did you hear the latest uh stock
market news one sub actually equals one
thank you so i recommend you guys get in
on that right now
thank you
there you go now you have to sub because
one thank you equals one so look i'm not
sure i'm running out of ways to say this
all right so last friday like an
absolute lemon i sat right here in this
chair and did a video talking about all
the excitement around cloud9 new league
coach ls the american-born korean
trained 400 iq controversial genius had
taken the lcs by storm after pulling out
some insane picks like ivan and soraka
mid to lead cloud9 to a 3-1 start to the
split things were looking up you could
even say he was on cloud nine i tried to
summarize the excitement around this man
by ending my video like this that's why
people are flocking to the church of ls
and yes if cloud9 fans are very lucky
and they say their prayers at night they
might just see a miracle this year
oh how wrong i was if i could go back in
time now i tell myself hey
maybe just wait one more day before you
say all of that stuff i'd also tell
myself to not get my hair cut quite so
sure it's a little bit itchy on saturday
lcs teams faced off in the league's
third week of the year with the final
game being a showdown between the
sergeant cloud9 and the flailing clg but
16 minutes 16 minutes before that game
took place cloud9 put out a tweet that
read ls has been released from cloud9
and max waldo has been promoted to the
lcs head coach position we would like to
thank ls for his contributions to the
team and wish him the best ls soon added
that he had only been informed of this
decision just a few hours prior and he
now had to figure out what to do next i
mean
this was mental this was really mental
i've been watching the lcs since day one
and i have never seen a coach get kicked
from a team so abruptly minutes before
they're due to go on stage and under
such mysterious circumstances and sure
enough as cloud9 took to the stage there
was max waldo in the head coach role
promoted from his usual position as
assistant coach the team went on to
crumble to clg a team that hadn't won a
game so far a team that cloud9 were
expected to smash but instead they got
battered by them zven tweeted what a
[ __ ] up day dude what's happening man
i don't want to over read into it or be
a drama andy or something
but like something bad must have
happened because this is weird i've
never seen a team just kick their coach
an hour before a game and everyone tweet
that's [ __ ] up
you could practically hear the question
mark pings as everyone trying to figure
out what the actual [ __ ] just happened
it just did not make sense a team with a
coach whose innovative drafts have been
drawing cloud nine a lot of praise have
been booted at the arse and just left on
the curb i i assumed that like
something happened he thought that like
things were going in a different
direction
maybe there was an ultimatum i have no
idea bro it's so hard to even
discuss this but it's so strange man
it's so strange like how could this
happen right now cloud9 shared nothing
else on that day ls signed off by saying
he was satisfied that he got to showcase
glimpses of his gameplay and drafts and
that he wished the staff and players all
the best and sure that sounds very nice
on the surface but you got the feeling
that this parting wasn't exactly
amicable like hedral said teams just
don't do this the speculation was that
extraordinary moves like this only
happen because of extraordinary
circumstances in other words there was a
huge bust up travis gafford interviewed
cloud9's fudge who was understandably
quite tight-lipped about the situation i
already like knew what was going to
happen so it wasn't like too bad for me
yeah um
obviously like once all the like all the
reasons come out for why it happened
blah blah blah
people will know like
why it happened but um for me it was
like whilst it was happening i sort of
knew
that there was problems
then once it finally happened i was like
yeah i sort of expected it to happen
okay so the speculation continued until
tuesday when cloud9 put out a video
titled on youtube our explanation and
what's next for cloud9 i was buzzing for
this i thought we were gonna get an
actual explanation here like okay cloud9
had a crazy week of collecting their
thoughts but now they're ready to tell
us the concrete details of what actually
happened so the speculation can finally
end but instead it was more like this
cloud9 for years has developed systems
on how we like to coach and operate our
team
and despite our best efforts working
with ls to try to come to uh terms and
see eye to eye on how that should work
we're unable to make that actually
happen i think it's important to note
that
all players coaches and management were
aware of these issues and frustrations
and our
mutual efforts to try to resolve them
over the last several weeks
unfortunately as time went on it was
really clear that we're unable to find a
resolution and come together on figuring
out this problem and we decided that it
was important that we make a change and
release ls at that point so we could
move forward and focus on the future so
yeah on the surface that does seem like
total pr speak from cloud 9's jack
etienne saying we didn't see eye to eye
doesn't really answer any questions it
just kicks them down the road a bit it
doesn't actually tell us what specifics
were disagreed upon between cloud9 and
ls and sure perhaps it's a bit naive to
expect an esports orc to spill their
guts about everything that happened this
video was a carefully crafted and
inoffensive message from cloud9 to their
fans intended to save them some face
after a weekend of pretty negative
attention now did it achieve that i'll
let you be the judge but i did find
something else jack said quite
interesting when he talked about the
coaching system he said the cloud9 and
ls couldn't come to terms with how to
make that coaching system work in other
words cloud9 had a coaching system and
for whatever reason ls's coaching style
simply didn't mesh with it but this only
adds even more questions because how did
they not see this coming ls is one of
the most transparent league minds out
there the bloke is an open book his
tendency towards off meta picks and
innovative strategies have been public
record for years and i have to be at
least part of the reason that cloud9
were interested in him in the first
place as i said in my video last week ls
had been working with cloud9 during the
offseason to put this roster together
the point is cloud9 had more than enough
time to know what he's all about it was
like a two-month-long job interview and
sure sometimes things seem great from
the outside until you get into it but
that still doesn't explain the abrupt
timing of it ls said he found out the
news hours before he was due to go on
stage so what did jack have to say about
that we know the timing of the decision
uh wasn't ideal we would have loved to
have had more time to create a larger pr
statement before the game on saturday
unfortunately we just did not have that
time available to us and we saw that it
was best for our team and for our
players to make that decision now
versus let the frustration increase i'm
not gonna sit here and judge every
explanation i personally think they're a
bit sanitized a bit vague and create
even more questions also the whole video
had a bit of an odd vibe if i'm honest
it kind of felt like a hostage video i
know jack was flanked by max waldo
summit and blabber to give it the whole
we're all in this together vibe but
i don't know felt a bit odd ls was on
his way back to his home in korea when
the video was released and everyone now
turned to him to hopefully hear some
actual details it wasn't too long until
ls jumped on stream was this the moment
we'd all been waiting for were we
finally gonna get some answers about
what actually happened
[Music]
this is the unfortunate reality
gentlemen
this is the unfortunate reality okay yep
the wait continues ultimately there are
many reasons why lawyers could be
involved was this because of something
to do with his time there was it solely
to do with his departure is one party in
the wrong or both who knows ella said
once again that he was happy with what
he had accomplished during his short
time at cloud9 that he hopes his future
perspectives on the game will be taken
more seriously as a result and that he's
proud of the players he coached and yeah
that's believable don't forget that ls
had a big hand in curating this team
this roster would not look the same
without him and now of course the
question is what will they look like now
that he's gone regardless of whether
they look better or worse without him
there's a real feeling in the community
that the lcs lost something this past
week you don't have to worship at the
church of ls you don't even have to like
him but you can't deny that for a couple
of weeks he made things pretty [ __ ]
interesting people were excited to see
how he was gonna draft how cloud9 were
gonna play what out of the box thinking
he was gonna bring to a region that is
in desperate need of change if it's ever
gonna stop being a meme on the
international stage bro and it kind of i
don't know i'm just kind of like sad
about i mean i was i was really liking
watching the games when ls was coaching
it's like it was something that was
super hype and i haven't seen
my chat be excited about lcs in
yeah years the only thing we know for
certain is that this whole ordeal has
left a pretty sour taste in ls mouth to
the point where he's now said he's never
returning to coaching again no i will
not be joining another team as coach
i have no intention on ever coaching
again
this this last
this last thing just
this [ __ ] just killed it for me
between hearing that and the fact that
lawyers are involved it's safe to say
that when the details of all this
finally do come out it's gonna be big
last week ls was a coach in the lcs as
part of cloud9 now he's none of those
things in the coming weeks and months
the league will be a bit quieter the
drafts a bit more predictable and the
mystery of what actually happened here
will only get deeper
i think they're gonna i think they are
gonna suffer in terms of like how far
they can go like i definitely think
their ceiling has dropped a bit right
like with ls on board there was genuine
conversations about them making around a
world you know
even getting to the finals right like in
2018 they they got the semis and there
was talk that this was the year cloud9
we're going to go one better and finally
get to the you know finals
personally i don't know if that's gonna
happen now not that it was gonna happen
for certain before but i like i say i
feel like the ceiling has come down a
little bit